[Music]
my name is dianna
bartschniebs i'm based in liesman in
[Music]
portugal
[Music]
my education was in a contemporary dance
and ballet
and then i started to make a fusion with
kind of acrobatic and aerialism
and then i got an accident and i won
a wheelchair so i start dancing also
with my disability
so i find this new body
and i start recovering actually from
from my accident through dance dance
for me have this kind of special meaning
of magic state
[Music]
in my work i like to
mix normative bodies with no normative i
like to use bionic
things on stage i'm also very open
to collaborate in terms of sounds
lights space
i like the audience surrounding near
and this kind of communication between
[Music]
the performer and the audience
my body is an accident so
i feel all the bodies are kind of an
accident of society
so i try to create an idea of shock
and landscape of bodies that are
conventional and not conventional
and they are very similar in between so
you cannot understand what's the
convention
of these bodies so i try to work in this
idea
and in terms of performance i like this
idea of hypnosis
and this idea of a different time zone
from reality
i like to show the body i feel like
persons with disability not often very
often show their body
on stage i like to
show what we are and uniqueness of that
and it's
quite interesting to see that we are not
all the same
[Music]
the importance of the body is much more
important to me now
[Music]
you